ambiance super production dans le jardin
de la grande maison créole du musée de
villèle un des nombreux sites du conseil
départemental qui est à l'honneur sur
les jeunes du groupe presstv ville elle
est un endroit qui est incontournable
madame desbassyns et nous a raconté une
histoire à la réunion fait partie de
tout de toute cette construction donc
c'était important pour nous de montrer
et d'illustrer la réunion avec cet
endroit nous sommes allés à la villa du
département qui est vraiment magnifique
où on a tourné avec audrey dardenne on
va faire un bel événement dimanche au
jardin de l'état et puis vidéo non mais
mon pays comment le
ça parle ça nous allait nourrir est la
même
une richesse patrimoniale qui sera vu
dans 140 pays mais aussi sur 9 7 4 tv
même si cela n'est pas l'essentiel il
est vrai que pour le musée soit de velez
on dirait qu'il ya un engouement qui est
peut-être dû au fait de la beauté du
site qui est aussi du fait de son
histoire avec une histoire à la fois au
passé sombre et douloureux et puis à
cette histoire qui évoque toute
l'histoire de la réunion alors je ne
sais pas si ça fait du bien parce qu'il
faut reconnaître que la mission
essentielle du musée c'est d'ailleurs
d'abord assurer la conservation du
milieu et la protection et la
préservation des collections mais il est
vrai que ça contribue à la notoriété et
donc ça sur une communication pourrait
on dire ça c'est très très important et
puis ça montre que ce sont aussi des
lieux vivants qui sont totalement
inscrit dans la modernité et qui sont
des vies tiennent du temps présent de la
société réunionnaise six modules de 26
minutes avec pour thème la zumba et pour
vedette des artistes le coup j'aime
beaucoup ce qu'a fait voilà notre notre
pays pour ce pour ce lieu j'espère qu'il
sera toujours aussi bien entretenu c'est
une émission qui dans des causes c'est à
dire qu'elle est vraiment beaucoup
regardé la zumba ça fait ça fédère
beaucoup beaucoup de monde
maintenant je suis pas spécialiste mais
au fait qu'est de mai viennent et que
c'est une grande spécialiste je trouve
que oui je trouve ça super tout ça
vraiment super g pas de ta ta ta un
petit peu ridicule mais j'ai vraiment
envie de partager ça avec et qui a une
musique qui est rythmée qui est
entraînante qu'un message tu peux
adapter tu peux le faire le principe de
la zumba c'est internationale ça s'ouvre
à toutes les cultures ça sonne à tout
les multis parce que c'est au soleil
était plus chargé de travail
peut-être même d'autorité mais pas
spécialement oui voilà mais on va
travailler mais dans une ambiance
peut-être un peu plus fun que quelle
époque quoi donc par respect pour les
personnes qui sont venues ici qui ont
beaucoup qui ont eu peut-être une autre
vision une autre approche je vais dire
qu'on va travailler me convient de
mettre un peu plus de joie et de bonheur
de force d'énergie positive c'est
possible de tout de tout conjugué
puisque ça fait partie de la découverte
de l'île et la zumba n'est qu'un alibi
pour faire découvrir la réunion c'est
vraiment la mission première de cette
émission
énergie et bonne humeur la petite
dizaine de sites du département prend
finalement chaque jour des couleurs